thank you
very nice
this video is a Mark Zuckerberg and I
Lex Friedman training Jiu Jitsu a
martial art with the goal of attaining
positional dominance of your opponent
and then to submit them by breaking
their arm or leg or choking them
unconscious but stopping right before
that as your opponent Taps twice to
designate that they give up
I'm a black belt in Jiu Jitsu and I've
been doing it for over 15 years and also
Judo and wrestling for 10 more Mark has
been training Jiu Jitsu for just over a
year and has taken this journey on with
humility and with the seriousness that
to me is truly inspiring this was
recorded shortly after our recent
podcast conversation and given the
recent back and forth between Elon and
Zuck on social media I should mention
that I'm a longtime friend of Elon and a
new friend of Zuck and I'm excited to
see them take on the Journey of being
martial artists in their own way and I
look forward to training with each of
them
they both run large successful impactful
companies and so they're super busy but
I do believe there's tremendous value in
them practicing martial arts as it will
make them better leaders better human
beings and students of human nature
first and foremost at least to me
Jujitsu is humbling and humility is a
powerful tool for Innovation and
Leadership
let me quote here as one must the great
Miyamoto Musashi a Japanese swordsman
and Warrior philosopher from the 17th
century
think lightly of yourself and deeply of
the world
that said this is a martial art and so
he also did say that the way of the
warrior is the Resolute acceptance of
death
in this video you see Mark and I doing
live Technical Training and some
practice of techniques under the
guidance of the legendary Jiu-Jitsu and
Judo instructor Dave Camarillo and now
dear friends here's Mark Zuckerberg and
I traineesome jiu jitsu
too
thank you
[Music]
all right smart
there's no friends
[Music]
okay
10 minutes away
all right you know what you guys go
sorry
[Music]
okay
nice
[Applause]
you're gonna have to stand up and make
it shake off all right
[Music]
foreign
hold the elbow
s
you could lock your leg Yeah
come on
[Music]
yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
that was awesome all right time for one
more let's put Mark and Lex together one
last time
we had such a great run on this one all
right position too take that Max come on
bud you need to use pins you gotta next
down and pin them
this one
yeah
Nick double up on that get on with the
doubling
eyes
[Applause]
when he has that Guillotine turn away
from the out like turn towards the elbow
you know what I mean yeah
left shoulder is tight rabbits rabbits
uh neck or trap in it
Watch That Monkey Joe head up yeah
posture
what's your left knee push his left feet
just head down keep your head down
shoulder pressure
nice
which way do we walk
solar pressure
walk out back elbow back Nick
so you might always be doing something
on the other hand questions
forward forward
there you go yes send them down nice
Smart Watch yeah
very nice
transition
everything out
okay
[Music]
yes yeah
it's good shoveling you down step over
lift your leg up and step up pull it
over dog
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
all right guys
thank you